here's this minion brandon what up i
gotta king it or sting it for you
it's not the face mask
it's not the handle bar yard you know
the king that
oh
right so spring breaker you know
desperate times call for desperate
measures right now
i usually get that hockey haircut that
gender neutral haircut
but all them barbers be closed so
that's why i ended up with king or sting
it what do you think
and brandon wear your helmet we don't
want you to be the next chris benoit
or aaron hernandez you're probably one
concussion away from that so
i don't wear a helmet or that brain
bucket gang [ __ ] that's fair
and [ __ ] bro also no one forced you to
get cornrows bro
that's a pretty extensive process to get
done
have you ever had cornrows cat no it's a
really it's a cat it seems like you
would have them you'd look cool really
you'd look sick your sisters had them no
really no oh interesting i feel like you
have a very specific image of what my
life
is and it's not right off every time
damn whale yeah i see you're definitely
cornrows a lot of diaries
yeah diaries um they see a rap video
dowry or diary diary
cornrows is a commitment heard it hurts
too yeah i heard it hurts and if you're
in the sun you need to put sunblock like
between the little skinny
areas the younger younger wow
did you wear cornrows for your
graduation
trip question see dinner right away
no i was bald headed for my graduation
though full manchu though man it's tough
to pull off
yeah also girls think you're a real
creep when you got that is that that
full manchu that's that full man chew
it's it's i thought it was fu manchester
it is
it is i call it full manchu yeah i like
the but the full manchew is when you
also have the bottom huh yeah yeah
you got that baby bucket old asian old
asian guys oh yeah
asian people what are we talking about
what are we talking about yeah tell us
more chen
that's what it is is that a mustache
yeah luckily i'm
one of the very few asians that could
actually grow facial hair but it's still
spread out
but this if i want to grow long it can
go forever
ooh and why is that i don't know see
that's a foo
oh damn his teeth are dope
it looks like a friend of mine that's
black magic
you have a friend that looks like that a
little bit but he's a lot younger but
he's gonna look like that one
does his teeth look like that no
his name is
is he vietnamese quoc yeah vietnamese
yeah
how do you know so many vietnamese
people
when i see them i say hey hey hey
and then they're friends everyone wants
to be deals friends because i'm curious
we didn't have a lot of them growing up
you know so you see him you get fired up
hey buddy
you know what y'all doing he's like who
like you know who
[Laughter]
island boy yeah you know who you call
island boy
yes they probably like that yeah they do
everybody does yeah who doesn't want to
be an island boy
[Music]
is